- C'est d'abord à Madrid et
à Londres que sont apparus,
la semaine dernière,
les premiers cas de variole
du singe, une maladie virale
rare, plus fréquente en Afrique
de l'ouest que dans
les capitales européennes.
Quelques jours plus tard,
de nouveaux cas se sont ajoutés
en Espagne et au Royaume-Uni,
mais également au Portugal
et aux États-Unis.
Et maintenant, c'est ici,
à Montréal, qu'on découvre
une éclosion.
Dre MYLÈNE DROUIN, dir. région.
santé publique de Montréal
- En date d'aujourd'hui,
on a 17 cas suspects dans
le Grand Montréal, 15 sur
l'île de Montréal, et un, et unn
sur la couronne sud et un sur
la couronne nord de Montréal.
- Le premier cas remonterait
au 29 avril. Les porteurs sont
tous des hommes homosexuels
de moins de 50 ans qui ont été
infectés par échange de fluides
contaminés durant un contact
rapproché. La vari
singe cause différents symptômes
visibles sur la peau, mais sauf
exception, ils disparaissent
après quelques semaines.
- On a pas à paniquer àl'échell.
On le voit clairement là,
ça prend des contact étroits.
Donc, en faisant votre épicerie,
en prenant le métr
vos activités, il n'y a
pas de risques actuellement.
- Il n'y pas de traitement
spécifique pour soigner cette
maladie, mais au Royaume-Uni,
on administre une dose
du classique vaccin contre
la variole à titre préventif.
Le Dr Pilarski, qui a deux
porteurs de ce virus parmi sa
clientèle, croit qu'on devrait
adopter la même stratégie.
Dr ROBERT PILARSKI,
Clinique Médicale La Licorne
- Idéalement, à mon avis,
ça aurait été de vacciner
monde qui est autour
des personnes qui sont déjà
atteintes, qui sont déjà avec
les éruptions, la maladie
puis, diminuer les risques
de transmission.
- Selon lui, l'apparition
de ce virus dans un cercle
restreint de personnes n'est
qu'un concours de ncours de nco.
- Comme la première personne,
c'était un homme qui avait
des rela des hommes,
donc j'imagine qu'il a eu
contact juste avec des hommes,
d'où la propagation homosexuelle
uniquement. Mais si c'était
une femme hétérosexuelle,
un homme hétérosexuel, ça aurait
pû arriver aussi. Le virus,
il choisit pas la race,il choisn
sexuelle ou le sexe.
- La santé publique de Montréal
a tenu à rappeler que la variole
du singe n'est pas considérée
comme une infection transmise
sexuellement et que son mode
précis dsion
reste encore à définir.
Ici Normand Grondin,
Radio-Canada, Montréal